bonsoir les jeux et cartes se poursuit
sous une météo toujours capricieuse je
suis à l'hippodrome de caen la prairie
comme on l'appelle ici
le site a nécessité près de 10 mille
tonnes de matériaux pour être aménagés
pour accueillir les compétitions
d'attelage ou de parra dressage le para
dressage qui justement aujourd'hui fait
partie des épreuves résumé des
calendriers sportifs avec franck besnier
des sites sous le soleil la pluie
enfin cesser première cavalière à se
présenter sur la piste de l'épreuve de
parra dressage nathalie mise et la
beauvaisienne de 48 ans malvoyantes est
une habituée des grands événements et
tendez bien l'oreille
l'entraîneur de nathalie dit de la
cavalière dans son parcours sur le carré
dressage je ne vois pas les lettres
donc en fait j'ai une personne qui est à
l'extérieur de la carrière qui m'annonce
la lettre au moment où la tête de mon
cheval y passe ce qui me permettent de
fermer mouvement de manière précise
comme si je voyais les elle est pour
l'instant sixième du classement général
avant la deuxième manche
ambiance survoltée au parc des
expositions
l'équipe de france de reining au grand
complet est là pour encourager le local
de l'étape
bastien bourgeois ce normand de 27 ans
partage sa vie entre bellengreville près
de caen et dieppe
ils montrent un étalon de sept ans lui
qui depuis hier les américains écrase le
concours
bastien donne tout mais ça ne suffit pas
je suis un peu déçu du score où ça va
pas forcément
et est ce que j'attendais j'attends un
petit peu plus l'aller les jugeons
portrait nitc voilà c'est qu'on disait
c'est du haut niveau là c'est dur
d'aller chercher des points
la déception du jour c'est la
contre-performance de franck perrais le
cavalier de la région centre son cheval
lui c'est leur luna part à la faute avec
une ruade résultat 5 points de pénalité
une soixante quatorzième place au
général c'est fini pour le doyen équipe
de france et puis au dressage l'émotion
de jessica michel la sociétaire du haras
de hus en loire atlantique elle aussi
quitte le concours pour seulement
quelques dixièmes de points
malgré tout elle est heureuse d'avoir
participé à ses premiers jeux équestres
qui veut aller loin ménage sa monture ce
proverbe prend tout son sens
particulièrement pendant les jeux
équestres mondiaux pour les chevaux de
compétition leur état de santé est
suivie en permanence
tout est contrôlé et tout est fait pour
leur plus grand confort exemple au haras
du pin en tout 35 vétérinaires seront
sur le site au moment des épreuves une
clinique a été installé pour gérer les
chevaux malades ou blessés on a cinq
boxes qu'on appelle des bugs frottement
qui permettent aux vétérinaires des
clips de traiter leurs chevaux on a
toute une série de bureaux pour les
vétérinaires on à la pharmacie on peut
tous traités on va dire les premières
urgences
et puis dès que ça va devenir un petit
peu compliqué nécessitant beaucoup de
médicaments ou en tout cas des moyens
peut-être un peu plus important que ce
qu'on a ici c'est évacuer référés vers
des cliniques à l'extérieur pour que
rien ne vienne perturber les jeux
équestres les vétérinaires suivent la
santé des chevaux de très près dès leur
arrivée un premier examen est réalisée
pour évaluer l'état général de l'animal
fréquence cardiaque vaccination
températures tout est vérifié comme pour
les athlètes de haut niveau
les diagnostics doivent pouvoir être
fait au plus vite sur le site un
laboratoire est opérationnel 24 heures
sur 24 on va frotter un peu la muqueuse
nasale du chemin j'accueille quelques
quelques cellules et les éventuels les
aventures des agents pathogènes qui
pourrait que le cheval pourraient avoir
l'objectif détecter les animaux malades
pour éviter toute contamination
au total 178 binaires sont mobilisés
pour ces jeux équestres sur les
différents sites
welcome to the wall street games in
normandie
on ne le dit jamais assez mais les
grands événements sont souvent possible
grâce aux bonnes volontés celle des
bénévoles ici sur tous les sites ils
sont près de 3000 pendant la quinzaine
et au village où je me trouve
actuellement ils sont près de 650 parmi
lesquels pauline bonjour poli aux jeunes
alors comment en êtes-vous arrivé alors
on s'inscrit sur internet ils ont ouvert
un site spécial pour les bénévoles
on postule on répond ce qu'on aimerait
faire tout ça après on a des entretiens
donc ses environs du mois de décembre et
au mois de décembre
on essaye de nous affecter un poste qui
ne correspond plus et la chose avant
tout qui fait qu'on va être restée la
motivation sur le site du village vous
êtes près de 650 bénévoles de toutes les
nationalités une obligation une
nécessité pour accueillir ce public
venus du monde entier
regardez et mon ami vient de là bas qui
aime le cheval ne compte pas les
kilomètres
quatrièmes jeux games gt1 grèce en 2002
l'entraîneur faisait partie de l'équipe
du canada
je suis allé à aix-la-chapelle la mecque
du cheval 6 en 2006 et en 2010 j'étais à
lexington et maintenant nous voilà en
nombre au point infos 4 et touriste
australienne veulent savoir où s'arrête
la navette gratuite qui dessert les
lieux de compétition
elles sont venues jusqu'en normandie
pour vivre les jeux entre copines et le
monde entier s'est donné rendez vous
sous l'abribus
oui c'est vrai
ce serait bien en fait c'est comme à la
maison il y pleut il fait froid sur la
côte ouest de la suède
en service à la clientèle cassé
le plaisir s'il ya du beau temps c'est
tout beau ni siffle sur format brillant
soleil
bonne journée hélas trop certainement
dire on termine en beauté avec un
extrait d'une qui dévie dame marocaine
une version artistique de ce rituel du
maghreb
cinq chevaux de type barbara b5 cavalier
du haras national de marrakech je vous
laisse admirer